Hello Freak bitches.
So speaking of a citizen Kane,
Orson wells and conspiracies last night
I rewatched the episode of Geraldo
Rivera is good night America when they
introduced the Zapruder cause you know,
Dick Gregory just died. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They introduced this approved or
film to the American public, uh,
13 years or 12 years, 12 years
after Kennedy's assassination. And,
uh, then I went and read that paper, uh,
the articles that was the printed
a couple of weeks ago that a,
you even tweeted about it,
about the CIA questioning the official
story of the JFK assassination. Yeah.
Yeah. That was interesting, wasn't
it? Yeah. It pass a CIA guy.
What do you think about that?
Well, first of all, Zapruder
film I ate,
that's the most watched piece of film
in history of film has it really,
which is really interesting. Um, but
uh, yeah, it was interesting that the,
you know,
as typical with a lot of these things
that the headline doesn't necessarily
actually match once you get
into the body of the story.
But the idea being that the agency
had some concerns over
the idea that perhaps Cuba was behind
the assassination Wa the Russians to some
degree or more likely in a
combination of the two. Um, look,
I think, you know, I do, I
think that, uh, that, uh,
he could have taken that shot. Yeah.
It was not a, yeah, it was not, I said,
I've been up in that book depository from
that point of view, that vantage point.
We did a story on the, on
the, uh, the whole, uh,
issue of the conspiracy theory
and what could have happened.
Then we tried to find some
new witnesses and, you know,
could he have made that shot?
Yeah. That was, uh, that was,
it was a straightforward,
you know, effort with someone who
had some training. He was, you know,
he wasn't the world's best shot,
but he had sufficient training to make
that shot. No, that's separate from,
you know,
his motivations and any potential support
that he may have gotten a during the
course of that. And, you know,
I think that he, in his mind,
he, he genuinely felt that this was going
to get him into the revolution, right.
That this was going to,
he had a very unhappy experience in
Russia when he was over there living,
came back,
saw what was happening in Cuba,
desperately wanted to be
part of that, uh, took, uh,
unexplained trip down in Mexico.
Uh,
which could well have been in an effort
to find somebody who could support his,
his desire to,
to take some sort of action,
whether he had formed in his mind that's
what he was going to do at the time or
not. So, you know, is there
a still a possibility that,
um, the Cubans, which would there,
the Intel service there would have had
to file on him? I mean, he was a very,
very well known quantity.
Obviously by that time for the Russians,
the Russians are solely responsible for
training up the Cuban Intel service.
So there's a massive file on
him. And they knew, you know,
who they were dealing with. They knew
his weaknesses. They knew his, um,
they knew his motivations.
They knew what to do in terms of trying
to get leverageable, you know, um,
information on him. So I think that
the jury is still out. I'm not,
and I'm not a conspiracy guy,
but I think there's
enough there that says,
you know, yes, it's kind of like what
we're talking about, climate change.
I believe this, but I, this
is, this also could be true.
I think he could have taken
that shot and for sure, uh,
and, and, and, and succeeded.
I think it's also possible that he
may have had the encouragement of,
in particular the Cuban until service,
uh, through the Russians. They were,
because at that time in particular,
they didn't do anything there.
Cubans didn't do anything without the
Russians support blessings and direction.
So that is entirely possible.
Um,
do I think that there were a variety of
other things at play, you know, was it,
did they help him get the, the, uh,
the weapon? Did they, I mean, you know,
it was her actual logistical support in
there. I don't who did, I don't think so.
But that'd be on maybe. Yeah, it's,
it's a, it's a fascinating thing. And,
and you know, again, nobody wants
to think that something that, uh,
impactful could have been
just one guy who, you know,
had a dream about being a hero of
the revolution, that they just,
it's such an awful thing to think about.
You want something bigger,
you want something more
behind it. And it's, it's,
I will say the one thing that I
think there was something else too,
was the MLK issue of Martin
Luther King assassination.
Well, let's get to that for sure.
But here's the thing about the,
the Lee Harvey Oswald assassination.
You know,
a lot of people think that there was
people in the grassy knoll and that they
shot at the president and there was more
than one shooter. That's possible too.
And here's the other problem with people
saying that Oswald could have never
made that shot. Of course he could
have a 100% he could of, is it likely,
listen,
people throw three point shots that
have no fucking business on a basketball
court and they hit nothing but
net. It happens all the time. Yeah.
It doesn't mean it's,
it's not likely that a guy could
get off three shots that quick,
but it is possible.
Well, there was more time in there than
they originally thought. There's been,
there's some misinformation out there
about how condensed that timeframe was and
now after they've,
if they've researched into a fare thee
well at that timeframe extended a little
bit, but he had, more
importantly, he worked up there.
So he had the opportunity to recky
that site. Right. So he was like,
he was sitting in a blind weight
and, and figuring out, you know,
what am I going to be doing here?
And that's a tremendous
advantage and clear daylight.
Target's moving right in the
line with you. There's no wind.
Not only that, it's not
that far shot. No, it's not.
It's not like everybody thinks it's like
a half mile away or something like that.
I mean, how far was it? It was 150
yards or something like that. Yeah,
I'd have to go back and it's been fine,
but I've stood on that spot where the
limo was and hooked up on the site and I
stood up there and not that far down.
And it's not that far.
And it's a total makeup. Makeable
shot on a deer. Yeah. I'll give you,
we're going to shoot a deer with
a rifle. He be like, Oh yeah,
that's definitely an effective
range. No, there was no,
how far is it would go 260 feet.
meters. That ain't shit. Yeah, that's
a bowshot. Yeah. You could shoot a,
an animal with a bow from 80 meters if
you're really good and there's no wind.
Yeah. So that's a really close shot. So
the idea that he couldn't make that shot,
he's a bad shot.
That is so fucking stupid.
He absolutely could make that shot and
that anybody could make that shot from 81
meters. That's nothing. We
looked at the grassy knoll issue.
We looked at the end of the day. What,
what the, the train yard engineer, um,
reported seeing,
um,
with a sort of a puff of smoke that he
thought he saw over by the fence line.
And, and we looked and he's like, yeah,
you could, you know, from that position,
they opened that place up and we were
able to go back up there and you could see
it.
We ran a couple of tests and fired off
a few shots and that's always fun if you
want to have got a good time to take a
rifle to Dealey plaza and fire off a few
shots without the tourist knowing
what the hell is happening.
And The Dallas police, by the way, were,
were tremendous during the course of that.
But, um, why don't you guys do this?
And we did this a while back for a
show called American declassified,
which isn't running anymore, but
it was on a, on a travel channel.
Jesse Ventura did that.
He went up there and with a
mantle linker carcanos same rifle.
And I was like awful shock.
No one could make the shot.
Please dawn. I love Jesse.
I think he's awesome.
That's everything.
Did conspiracy
significantly on that side. It's to
the point where, you know, that's,
he's leaning always toward the conspiracy,
which you want to do is you want to do
every investigation. And I, you know,
this company that I've got, we,
we do a lot of investigations, we,
and you've got a bill just like with
a homicide case or anything else,
you've got to build it on
stable ground. Right? Right.
So you have to start from the very basics
because if you start building ideas
and investigative inquiries on something
that's not sturdy underneath it,
you know, not based on evidence and
fact, then you've got a problem.
The whole thing becomes
suspect and usually comes
toppling down. So, you know, I,
you got to keep an open mind about all
these things and I think it's important.
Um, right now people are
like, Oh, well I'm sure that
agency, the CIA was involved.
So I'm a terrible source of information.
I've, I've heard that before. I said,
you can't talk credibly about this
because you know, the CIA was involved in,
I think he is a thing of the CIA was
involved. It's not you, you weren't there.
And I was 62 last time I checked.
I was not there in 1962 and a,
and also I will tell you this much.
Or was it 63 it was 66 58 63 if the age,
if the agency had been involved,
this is the honest to God's truth.
There's no way that secret is still kept.
People can't keep their Yap shot.
They can't.
And secrets have a way of coming out and
certainly a lot quicker now than they
used to. So now the idea
that secrets then, I mean,
we're talking about so
long ago, how much, yeah.
Talking to him more than 50 years ago,
it's like, you know, it's like, get out.
It's like the DB Cooper issue.
My biggest reason for believing db Cooper
died and his shoot is hanging off a
tree and that's a vast wilderness
up there. Yeah. Is, uh,
is it people just,
they can't help themselves at some point,
people talk or somebody talks,
somebody associated with,
or somebody nearby or somebody involved
with somebody on their deathbed or
somebody said something they
shouldn't have. Um, it's, you know,
the idea that they've maintained this
sort of secret over a period of time,
I find hard to believe I'm
not discounting it. And again,
you've got to leave a little space open
for something that could be just amazing.
But anyway, so that's,
that was that. But I, yeah,
I agree. That shot was not, uh, was not
a tough shot. One meters ain't shit.
That's nothing in particular
in those conditions.
And I will say those conditions were
ideal. Unfortunately for that event.
People are like,
there's a video of me shooting a
fucking hard drive at a hundred yards,
a hard drive. You must hate
it. That hard edge. Oh wait,
you're just getting rid of some hardships
and thought it'd be fun to take it to
the rifle range.
So I take it to the right for it.
And obviously we're dealing with modern
rifles are probably more accurate,
but I'm shooting something
that's basically two inches high,
laying it down on the ground at a 100
yards and blown to smithereens. Yeah.
That's how accurate a rifle
is at a hundred yards.
You tell me he couldn't get a
headshot at 81 meters. That's crazy.
Again, Marsico wind of course he
could go to light. Did he though?
Who did he that's right. Yeah. That's
the question. The question is, you know,
we have some pretty good indication
as to what he was thinking and what is
obviously what his motivations
were and that's important.
It definitely was in with the Russians
definitely was involved in a lot of weird
shit with communism.
Who knows what his entire full background
was cause there was a lot of covert
shit going on.
Right.
Did He,
did he express a desire to do something
like this to the Russians at some point
and they, you know that, okay, well here's
an interesting opportunity, right? Yeah.
They would have,
they would have sparked on that and they
would have thought about it. They would.
They have actually, you know,
no play on words intended,
but would they have pulled the trigger
on an operation trying to push him into
doing an act like this? Maybe
indirectly through the Cubans. Exactly.
Especially, they thought like this crazy
fuck might go ahead and do this for us.
Yeah.
So after the Bay of Pigs,
people have to realize there was a
lot of people pissed off at Kennedy.
We locked the shot.
Hey Buddy hated Kennedy. Yeah. And so
well that infamous video where he's
banging his shoe down on a table,
we will bury you.
Yeah, yeah. No, it was, it
was, uh, the, the environment
was right for them and they,
and again,
the Russians,
it shouldn't be any surprise to anybody
when you talk about what they did during
this election. I mean, they've
been doing this forever, you know,
they've been there.
You go back to 1940s and,
and the Russians were spending a lot of
time and effort and money here in the
states trying to keep us out of the
war back before Hitler invaded Russia,
when they were allied with the
Nazis still. So they spend,
a lot of times they set up
independent association.
Supposedly they paid off a lot of unions
and union members know journalists.
I mean they were doing everything they
could to create this or to strengthen the
idea of isolationism just to keep us out.
They've been doing this for as long as
they've been around, so anybody who says,
well, I can't, you know, it's,
it's shocking. The Russians
would be engaged. This is,
that's ridiculous.
They've always been. Again, we by the way,
have been engaged doing that with them.
What? That's what I hear.
Fine. I've heard that online.
I find that Alex Jones story,
I do believe that bothers me the most
about the Kennedy assassination is the
universal support for
the magic bullet theory.
I think that fucking bullet is ridiculous.
I've shot things.
I've shot a lot of things.
I know what happens to bullets.
Everybody that I know that's a marksman.
Everybody know that's a hunter.
They see a bullet that has hit bone.
It fucking never looks like that.
When a boat goes through to people and
comes out looking like you shot it into a
pool of water, that's what it looks
like. I don't buy that at all.
And the convenience of finding it on
Connolly's Gurney when they rolled them
into the hospital. Oh look guys, we found
the bullet. Got It. And it's perfect. God,
I don't buy that for a fucking second.
And the problem is there's more
metal fragments in Conley's body,
then we're missing from the bullet itself.
I think that bullet itself,
you look at that bullet get Gatti here,
that thing didn't hit shit.
No, it's exactly right.
The condition of this with people that
have never shot guns and they could watch
[inaudible] proven that's not that
broke bones and a bullet breaks bones,
they get fucked and well,
it's a jacketed bullets
when it's a jacketed bullet
breaks bones, it gets fucked.
Yeah. You're talking about
something that's going, I mean,
how fast is a bullet from that rifle go?
It's gotta be kind of that.
That would be interesting
thing to pull up,
but I would imagine it's in the thousands
of feet per second. It's got to be,
when it hits bone, it's just going to
blow up. There's always distortion.
Even if you're, I mean it, so I don't,
but when you have a conversation about
this and it is somebody who has no
shooting experience or you know,
it just, all right, that's fine.
I understand why you're fascinated by
it. But do, when you do your research,
you know, it's, it's like with
news, read everything, right?
Read The Wall Street Journal. I read the
New York Times, read the Financial Times,
read, read the economist,
but read everything before
you form your opinion. Right?
And, and, and everybody
is so siloed nowadays.
And you get the same thing
with conspiracy theories.
I absolutely believe this
and I'm not going to,
I'm going to discount everything
else that's out there and,
or just not pay any attention to
it. Um, yeah. But it's hard to say.
And here's another thing, the magic
bullet path. People are like, well,
how is that possible?
Well,
let me tell you something that's the
most believable thing about the magic
bullet.
There is the path of the bullet,
because bullets do wacky shit when they
hit bone and you can't predict it at all.
I know a guy who, uh, in Iraq,
they shot a guy in the head from the
front and it went out as eyeball.
The bullet came out of
his eyeball back forward.
It ricocheted inside of his skull and came
out as, I know you can't, I mean, again,
you can't put you right,
you can't predict it and they'll try to
model these things and figure out a way,
but you know, there's an unknown
there. And so, yeah, I agree. I mean,
I think that again, it's, it's
one of those things where it, it,
it's never going to get
resolved. Um, and it,
it's going to continue to live on because
a, it was such an important event in,
in the history
of the country and B, it's, I keep
going back to that same thing.
People don't want to believe that really
awful shit can happen sometimes in a
very simple,
straightforward way.
And so it's much easier to think
it was a broad base conspiracy.
There were lots of moving parts.
Sometimes bad shit happens in,
it's just as simple.
Plus it seems that it is possible.
Conversely,
people don't like to
believe in conspiracies,
especially when it's evolved
in an assassination of
president. Right. You know,
the, the reason why they came up with the
whole magic bullet theory in the first
place is pretty shady in
the first, in fact, they,
the reason why they did it because the
guy got hit by a ricochet underneath the
overpass and they blamed
that bullet on one of the,
one of the shots from Lee Harvey Oswald
and the book depository. So they said,
well, all right, so now we have less
bullets that could have hit Kennedy.
We have all these wounds and we have to
tribute a series of wounds to one bullet,
right? Right. So that was the,
the, the thought process behind it.
But the Zapruder film was the one
that got people weirded out by it.
But I tell you about,
man,
I've watched that film a bunch of times
and one of the things that don't jive is
if he did get hit from the front, you
know, his head goes back to the left.
Why is the blood spray out
forward? See it's, it's,
it's weird the way the
impact of the blood is the,
it's like the blood sprays forward and
then his head goes back into the left.
It could have possibly been that
he was hit from the front end,
the back at the same time.
That's entirely possible. I mean,
that is a tactic you would do,
right?
You would roll something into an area
where they would be in a crossfire and
they'd get shot.
Well, they came in, if there was,
if the grassy knoll was in fact
a second site for a shooter,
then by the time it hits that corner and
starts its path just before the shots
were fired from the book depository and
Oswald, if you, if you're going with that,
if you had another shooter up
on the grass, you know, you're,
you are basically looking right
at the, the, uh, the, the,
the front of the vehicle and because of
the way that it's positioned in the nols
kind of turned,
and then it's just that,
it's just that there's not a lot
of concealment up there. Right.
And they had that, they had
the defense, the picket fence.
It's not the original
one that's there anymore,
but it's basically in line with it.
And you can see there's plenty of
pictures of the, uh, previous fence.
It was up there at the
time. Um, and you had that,
you did have the train yard engineer
report sometime after the fact that he saw
a puff of smoke that he wasn't
quite sure what that was all about.
And he'd seen a couple of people
back there so that, you know,
that was, that's an interesting thread
to pull on. Right. And I think that,
that it's been, you know, it's
been researched ad nauseum.
It doesn't mean that you couldn't still
find something that also doesn't mean
anybody's going to really
find a conclusion after the
fact, right. Firstly today.
Yeah, no, and that's right. And you,
you know, it's like everything else,
as time marches on, you loose, you know,
you lose witnesses, you lose, you know,
people that were there on site. And
even witnesses, when someone gets shot,
especially with the president gets shot,
not credible.
You'll have five different stories from
five different people and gunshots heard
from the moon. Nobody knows what that fog
just from a of robbery, just straight.
Yeah. A car accident. And you
say, you'll say, what did you see?
If you separate people out,
you're right.
You get five different versions from five
different people. Yeah. And you know,
so yeah. I wasn't no waiting
to see a counselor at, tend
not to be a particularly,
uh, credible. And you've
got to, you know, you, you,
you got to take them and then you got to,
you know,
match it up with other information. You
can, you can pull together forensically,
but it's, uh, it is fascinating.
Okay.